es spielen bowling
warum hinten geht los ich fange an das
heißt ich manchmal die kamera hier so
ein bisschen was heraus wir stehen auf
oder wird gewollt
[Musik]
ich hab doch vorne die mittel gezielt
ja ich muss so schnell wird
[Musik]
muss das gedrückthalten
angedient ja zwei stunden
da geht es auch
[Musik]
ok man kann auf jeden fall nicht wenn
man es drückt nochmal die position
verändern von daher jetzt wieder direkt
mitte oder beim bowling ist doch
eigentlich immer so dass man so ein
bisschen
jan amos bisschen so seitlich und dann
so mit spinnen oder geht das mit 24
spielen das ist nicht rechtens
das so
ich glaube dass wir jetzt so ein
bisschen hier nach rechts
und dann
gewinnst du dich
verbessern war der esc neben als typ
[Musik]
ich kann das nicht
von luca sagt loso
gewannen sich um alles kümmern gesehen
ohnehin kurz
[Musik]
spareribs
ab jetzt nur noch streiks ich sag's wie
es ist
schreibt man in die kommentare ob ich an
stecken die fonds kaufen soll dann
spielen die anderen spieler von diesem
jahr das kam in europa wie schlecht bin
ich ja besser
[Musik]
häusliche gewalt
ich dachte die kurve
ich wollte mit spannung die ecke aber
das geht nicht
trotzdem
[Musik]
entspannt volkmer ich habe sie ganz
genau dass in der mitte sind sagt
wir schauen uns das ganze bei dem links
ab wie er wird
[Musik]
okay wir können auch so jetzt verstellen
zu machen sowie können auch
ich mache jetzt ganz von der ecke so so
machen sie's killer
handy kann ich nicht so gut
meist aber jetzt kommt der profi jetzt
musst du einfach wieder zu gucken wie
das geht
[Musik]
so
ist ihr anspruch der das nicht
[Musik]
so er spielt nämlich wenn man mit
leidenschaft dabei ist und ich wir alle
wissen war 1914 in kolumbien bowling
weltmeister geworden in kolumbien
kolumbien die hilfe ist kolumbien sind
mindesten von kolumbus entdeckt
ganz normal für dich darin heißt mit
kolumbien sondern cool um
jedoch panik
bloßgestellt
was soll das ich wollte den aus
halle
also mal ganz kurz für die kinder die
hier mit mir spielen man kann einerseits
sagen dass man so mit der oberen taste
aber man kann auch mit der linken taste
nach links sich drehen mit der rechten
nach rechts deswegen mache ich ja immer
diese tricks und mach jetzt aber durch
die beiden
ja wahrscheinlich siehst du nicht
trotzdem ich sehe im spiel hat wirklich
spaß gemacht denn meist ist treu
der weg ist weit
warum sollte denn jedes recht auf weil
den der nacht so hältst und nicht so
lässt weißt du
[Musik]
jetzt besser ich rein was zur frage
was hat was damit zu tun werde aber
wenn ich jetzt ich mache jetzt den
gleichen kurs aber ich drehe jetzt nach
links
dann geht jetzt nach links obwohl ich
genau weiß wochen habe ich hätte
ja ich habe generell noch nie
computerspiele gespielt und sich
brauchen die bauern also darf ist meine
form ist echt gut also falls sich
verlieren solltest dass die
entschuldigung ist ein bisschen schräg
werden
so wird das nix
gut
sorry wenn ich so werfen würde wie du
übels unterhaltsam das alles machen
würde
[Musik]
also nach macht man müsste man die
steuerung schon raus aber eigentlich
so ein charakter läuft der letzte kugel
mehr so mittendrin dann irgendwie fallen
und loslegen aber das sieht irgendwie
genauso aus wie echt bei mir
so
das war jetzt so tun als wenn wir
wirklich spielen also wir tun jetzt so
als wenn wir wirklich alle bowlingbahn
so
letzter wurf meine damen und herren
einer pro tag aus musik haben
oh
ich bin ich gespannt was gewonnen hatte
mal wieder im hintergrund hat seine 16
wenn euch das video gefallen hatte das
kind einen daumen hoch und video hier da
abonniert ein kanal und klickt auf die
wirkung bei trivadis nichts verpassen
welches video sollen wir als nächstes
machen was wir als nächstes spielen von
diesen spielen sondern mein tennis
gegeneinander wie was wo pipapo figaro
mexiko